IN A MEETING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE. EXCUSE ME? THE
MEETING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL BEGIN IN
15 SECONDS. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 113 OF THE
STATE CAPITOL FOR ANY ABSENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITHIN
EARSHOT, PLEASE COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
SO WE CAN, WHILE WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT WE'RE GOING
TO BE TAKING OR COUNTING VOTES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU GET
TAKEN CARE OF. AND FOR ANYONE
WHO HAS A BILL UP TODAY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE, I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE COME OVER. THIS WILL BE A
SHORT MEETING AND SHOULD YOU NOT
APPEAR ON TIME, WE MAY JUST
RECESS. SO WE HAVE SIX MEASURES
LISTED ON THE DAILY FILE ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, BUT WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED A B 3121 OR A B 3264,
YET. SO WE WILL ONLY BE HEARING
THE REMAINING FOUR MEASURES AT
THIS TIME. DUE TO THE LATE
TIMING OF THIS HEARING, ALL
MEASURES BEING HEARD TODAY WILL
BE ELIGIBLE FOR A DUE PASS
MOTION. BEFORE WE BEGIN, I WANT
TO REMIND ANY WITNESSES TO LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL. PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY IN YOUR COMMENTS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS LET US
KNOW THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE ANY
FILES FOR THE MEASURES BEING
HEARD TODAY, SO THEY WILL NOT BE
PROVIDING COMMENTS ON THESE
MEASURES BEFORE WE BEGIN HEARING
TESTIMONY ON THE MEASURES WE
NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MADAM ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO. HERE.
CABALLERO. HERE. JONES. I'M
HERE. JONES. HERE. ASHBY HERE.
ASHBY. HERE. BECKER. BRADFORD.
CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE WAHAB, DO
WE HAVE A QUORUM? SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE REGULAR
BUSINESS OF THE DAY. WE WILL
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
SENATOR GLAZER, YOU'RE HERE ON
AB 1205, PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. CHAIR. AND I
AM PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN BAUER-KAHAN.
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THIS BILL?
I'LL SPEAK TO THE FISCAL EFFECTS
DIRECTLY WHEN A STUDENT
GRADUATES ON TIME. THE GOOD NEWS
FOR THE STATE IS THAT MEANS
ANOTHER STUDENT CAN FILL THAT
SLOT. AND WE KNOW WE HAVE
IMPACTIONS IN A LOT OF OUR
CAMPUSES. THE BILL BEFORE YOU IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT. GETTING
KIDS THROUGH COLLEGE IN A TIMELY
WAY, NOT HAVING THEM LEAVE WITH
NO DEGREE AND NO DEBT. THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE SUNSET. ESTABLISHED
IN 2016, THE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE IN THAT YEAR WAS
19%. TODAY, IT'S 38% BECAUSE OF
THE WORK OF BILLS LIKE THIS AND
THE WORK OF THE LEADERSHIP ON
THE CAMPUSES, WE'VE REALLY MADE
GREAT PROGRESS DOUBLING THE
GRADUATION RATE IN EIGHT YEARS
AND THE COST SAVINGS THAT
PROVIDES, THERE'S MINOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CONTINUING THIS
PROGRAM AND A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. I THINK IT'S WELL
WORTH IT. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ESTÁ MØT. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE? I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
THERE IS A MOTION SAYING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES IS
NOT WITH US. SENATOR GLAZER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING ON TIME
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL AND
WE SAVE MONEY WHEN STUDENTS
GRADUATE ON TIME, AS DOES THE
FAMILY. SO I THANK YOU FOR THIS.
THERE IS A MOTION. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS PLEASE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES AYE. JONES. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
CIERTO AYE. CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB
SERVICE. 5 TO 0. THE VOTE IS 5
TO 0. IT. WE WILL PUT IT ON
CALL. I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GET
CONTROL OF THE COMMITTEE HERE.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO PUT THIS ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, WELCOME. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 2348. WE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A DUE PASS MOTION
TODAY. SO WELCOME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS,
AB 2348 IS A BILL THAT MAKES
SIMPLE CLARIFICATIONS TO THE
FEATHER ALERT COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE BILL ARE RELATED TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ACTIVATING THE FEATHER ALERT
ONCE REQUESTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. I ASK FOR YOUR.
I VOTE. VERY GOOD. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? AS I INDICATED TO
YOU PREVIOUSLY, THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS NOT WITH US. SO
WE'LL SEE. THERE IS A MOTION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? IF NOT, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU. I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING ON ON TIME AS WELL. VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT. BILL. SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES JONES.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. CIERTO.
CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB THAT BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES, 5 TO 0. WE WILL PUT
IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE TWO OTHER
AUTHORS THAT WERE WAITING FOR.
WANT TO SEE IF, EITHER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT OR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO OR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LUIS REYES IS WITHIN
EARSHOT. IT WOULD BE GOOD IF YOU
COULD GET OVER HERE. SO WE CAN
FINISH UP OUR HEARING TODAY AND
MOVE YOUR BILLS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. I'M ASSUMING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO YOU, SO WE'LL TAKE
A VERY QUICK RECESS AND SEE IF
WE CAN GET AHOLD OF EITHER ONE
OF THEM. NHÀ THE SECOND.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER. AND YOU'RE IN LUCK. TODAY
YOU GET TO HEAR FROM SENATOR
BECKER, WHO HAS AGREED TO
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER FOUR, WHICH
IS ACR 210, BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
AGREEING TO DO THAT TODAY. TAKE
IT AWAY. WE HAVE SOME TOUGH
QUESTIONS, SO BE PREPARED. ALL
RIGHT. SINCE WE WON'T GO INTO
DEEP DETAIL ABOUT MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS, BUT I AM HERE
TO PRESENT ACR 120, WHICH
DECLARES THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
FOR NEW AND EXISTING MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS AND URGES STATE
AGENCIES, COUNCILS AND
COMMISSIONS TO PRIORITIZE THESE
AREAS. AS THIS IS A RESOLUTION
DOES NOT HAVE FORCE OF LAW. I
AND IT IS RESOLUTION IS NOT A
FORCE OF LAW. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, AS WE ARTICULATED,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOW
WITH US TO COMMENT ON THIS. SO
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. VICTORIA OAN
WITH NRDC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO. LARA DIÆN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS? SEEING
NONE, THERE IS A MOTION. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
SENATE. FOR IT IS THE RESOLUTION
TO BE ADOPTED AND REFERRED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR? PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. JONES. NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. I. BECKER.
I. BRADFORD CIERTO. CIERTO. NO.
WAHAB VOTED 3 TO 2. CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 2. WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SO
NOW WOULD PROBABLY BE A REALLY
GOOD TIME TO ADVISE THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT THEY CAN BE ABSENT
NO LONGER. WE NEED THEM TO SHOW
UP SO WE CAN FINISH OUR HEARING
TODAY. AND THEN WE HAVE ONE MORE
BILL, WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 98 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUAN CARRILLO AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ELOISE REYES. AND I'M
TOLD HE'S ON HIS WAY. SO WE'LL
TAKE A RECESS FOR ONE MINUTE AND
SEE IF HE CAN MAKE IT IN TIME.
TAKEN UP. SO WE WILL BE IN
RECESS FOR A FEW MINUTES AND SEE
IF WE CAN GET OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE TO VOTE, AND THEN
WE'LL TAKE THIS UP WHEN THEY'RE
FREE TO GO.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER. WELCOME, ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE YOU
HERE WITH US. WE'RE ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 98, BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. WELCOME.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING SO
PATIENT WITH US. I'M SURE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
BEGIN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF AB 98,
PRESENTED HERE BY MY COLLEAGUE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO
AND MYSELF WILL PROVIDE A NUMBER
OF REGULATIONS REGARDING
GREENHOUSES, THE PURPOSE OF AB
98 IS TO PROVIDE COMMON SENSE
POLICIES RELATED TO THE SITING
AND PLANNING OF LOGISTICS
DEVELOPMENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
WHERE IN SOME AREAS LIKE THE
INLAND EMPIRE, WE HAVE OVER 4000
WAREHOUSES TAKING UP OVER
1,000,000,000FT², RESULTING IN
OVER 600,000 TRUCK TRIPS PER DAY.
AB 98 WAS PROPERLY DRAFTED, BUT
WE DO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
THERE ARE AREAS THAT STILL HAVE
SOME CONCERNS, AND WE'LL HAVE
WILL BE THE SUBJECT OF FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS IN THE FUTURE. THE
BILL DOES HAVE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS FOR THE COMMUNITY AS WE
MOVE FORWARD, INCLUDING PLACING
21ST CENTURY BUILDING STANDARDS
FOR NEW WAREHOUSES, PROHIBITING
HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCK MILES
FROM BEING ADJACENT TO SENSITIVE
RECEPTOR PROPERTY LINES, PLACING
MANDATORY UPDATE OF TRACK TRUCK
ROUTES STATEWIDE TO ENSURE
TRUCKS DO NOT ROUTE THEMSELVES
THROUGH RESIDENTIAL STREETS AND
COMMUNITIES, REQUIRING TWO FOR
ONE REPLACEMENT FOR HOMES
DEMOLISHED IN ORDER TO MAKE ROOM
FOR MORE LOGISTICS DEVELOPMENTS
AND 12 MONTHS PAYMENT TO
DISPLACED RENTERS. AB 98 PUTS IN
PLACE SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY LINE
BUFFERS FOR NEW WAREHOUSES AND
INCLUDED ALSO IN AB 98 IS AN
INTERIM REPORT IN 2028 THAT
ALLOWS FOR US TO TRACK OUR
PROGRESS IN REDUCING EMISSIONS
AND EVALUATING OUR NEXT STEPS.
AB 98 IS A PART OF THE WORK THAT
IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES. THIS
IS OUR FIRST STEP, NOT SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED OVERNIGHT. WE
HAVE. I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS VERY SUBJECT FOR ALMOST A
DECADE, SINCE I ARRIVED EIGHT
YEARS AGO, AND HAVE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION EVERY SINGLE
SESSION, AND I'M SO PROUD TO
HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARRILLO
TAKE THE LEAD IN THIS BILL TODAY
THAT WE PRESENT TO YOU. AND WITH
THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. VERY GOOD. I
NEGLECTED TO SAY WHEN YOU
ARRIVED, BUT I SAID IT
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING THAT THIS
ENJOYS A DUE PASS MOTION. GIVEN
THE LATENESS OF THE SESSION. SO
WE'RE GOING TO END THAT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL NOT
BE HERE TODAY TO RESPOND TO THE
COST IMPACTS TO THE TO THE STATE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
YOU TO COME FORWARD TO THE MIC,
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION. IF YOU COULD. YES
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING STAN.
FISCAL. YES. AND THE REMINDER IS
THIS IS THE FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE FISCAL.
YES, SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JAMES TH¤U. I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
LABORERS. WE REPRESENT OVER
80,000 MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK IN
THE HEAVY CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
MANY OF DIRECTLY WORK IN THE
TILT-UP AND WAREHOUSE LOGISTICS
SECTOR AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS FOR THEIR DEDICATION AND
HARD WORK ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS, THE LABORERS HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY IN GOOD FAITH WITH
MANY KEY STAKEHOLDERS, ALSO WITH
LEADERSHIP IN IDENTIFYING A
PRAGMATIC AND BALANCED APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING AIR QUALITY
CONCERNS ASSOCIATED WITH
LOGISTICS, AND PROTECTING THE
THOUSANDS OF UNION JOBS WITH
BUILDING THESE FACILITIES. AB 98
BRINGS INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
TACKLE IMMEDIATE AIR QUALITY,
SAFETY AND SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES,
WHILE ALSO BRINGING OUR
DISTRIBUTION PROCESS INTO THE
21ST CENTURY. THE WORK
ASSOCIATED WITH INDUSTRIAL
WAREHOUSE CONSTRUCTION HAS
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF HARDWORKING
LABORERS AND OTHER UNION MEMBERS
TO PURCHASE HOMES AND BUILD FOR
THEIR FAMILIES FUTURE IN THE
VERY COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
WORK. THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
US, AND WE TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN
DOING SO. THESE GROUPS THERE
WILL BE GROUPS AND ORGANIZATIONS
HERE TODAY WHO WILL ASK YOU TO
OPPOSE AB 98. THEY WILL CONTEND
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH. OTHERS WILL SAY IT GOES
TOO FAR. WE ASK YOU TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT
IS A BALANCED APPROACH. IT'S
FAIR FOR THE STATE, IT'S FAIR
FOR COMMUNITIES, AND IT'S FAIR
FOR WORKERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JOSE
GREENWALD HERE ON BEHALF OF UFCW
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL. AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE JUST
STAYING ON THE COST PART OF
THIS, I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS THE
HIDDEN COST TO COMMUNITIES AND
THE HIDDEN COST TO WORKERS. IF
WE DO NOT ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
ALLOW THE STATUS QUO TO CONTINUE.
RESEARCH HAS WELL DOCUMENTED THE
NEGATIVE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH IMPACTS OF WAREHOUSING.
SO THIS CAN COME AT THE COST OF
HEALTH IMPACTS DUE TO BAD AIR
QUALITY. SO FOLKS HAVING TO HAVE
INCREASED COSTS IN TERMS OF
HEALTH CARE, ESPECIALLY FOR
FAMILIES THAT DON'T HAVE
PREEXISTING CONDITIONS RELATED
TO ASTHMA AND OTHER THINGS, ARE
NOW HAVING TO TAKE THAT AS A
PART OF THEIR HEALTH PLANS.
ACROSS THE Tð, ACROSS SAN
BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES, THERE ARE OVER 4.6
MILLION AT RISK INDIVIDUALS
BEING EXPOSED TO UNHEALTHY AIR
LEVELS, UNHEALTHY LEVELS OF
OZONE, AND PARTICLE POLLUTION
EACH AND EVERY DAY. THE OTHER
NEGATIVE HEALTH, THE OTHER
NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT IS FELT
AMONGST COMMUNITIES IS AROUND
THEIR RESIDENTIAL HOMES BEING
DEMOLISHED, OR DEPRECIATION IN
VALUE FOR FOLKS THAT CAN'T
AFFORD HOMES. SO THAT IS ANOTHER
COST THAT'S HIDDEN TO
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS TO
WORKERS. AND THEN JUST GOING
BACK TO THE HEALTH IMPACTS, IF
FOLKS ARE HAVING TO MISS DAYS
DUE TO HEALTH IMPACTS FROM BAD
AIR QUALITY, THAT'S DAYS MISSED
AWAY FROM WORK. SO THAT IS
COMING FROM WORKERS HAVING TO
USE PAID SICK DAYS, OR TAKING
UNPAID LEAVE, OR IN THE COST OF
DAYCARE BECAUSE SCHOOLS WILL
SHUT DOWN DUE TO BAD AIR
QUALITY. AND SO THERE'S JUST A
LOT OF HIDDEN COSTS TO
COMMUNITIES WHEN IT COMES TO THE
IMPACT OF WAREHOUSING. AND IT IS
UNJUST TO PLACE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH BURDEN ON HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE SEEING STAGGERING DECLINE IN
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE. WHEN
THESE FACILITIES ARE SITED NEXT
TO THEIR HOMES, SCHOOLS, PARKS
AND OTHER SENSITIVE RECEPTORS.
WHILE THIS BILL IS NOT PERFECT,
WE STILL THINK IT MOVES THE
MOVES. CALIFORNIA IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TOWARDS PROTECTING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. BUT
MORE WORK IS STILL NEEDED. BUT
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT MORE WORK IS
STILL NEEDED, WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO ESTABLISH
THIS BASELINE STANDARD OF
PROTECTIONS FROM WAREHOUSE
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MARK FAROOQ, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
BEN GOLOMBEK, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
OUR OFFICIAL POSITION IS
NEUTRAL, BUT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS STRONG COMPROMISE MOVING
FORWARD AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S HARD WORK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
KEITH DUNN, ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL OF IRONWORKERS,
AS WELL AS THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT, APPRECIATE THE YEARS OF
WORK BY THE AUTHOR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. TODD
BLOOMSTEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
RYAN. ELAINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION, OFFICIAL
NEUTRAL POSITION IN WITH OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CHAMBER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MELANIE PERRON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
OF CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, PAT JOYCE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. SIMILARLY ALIGNED
OR NEUTRAL BUT SUPPORTIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. COURTNEY JENSEN
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
WAREHOUSE LOGISTICS ASSOCIATION,
IN A NEUTRAL POSITION, BUT ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH CAL CHAMBER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY CHAU
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT MALIK
BYNUM, UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
LOCAL 3930 IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION?
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WELCOME
MELISSA SPARKS KRANZ WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. I'M
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB 98.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, AB 98 WAS
INTRODUCED FOR THE FIRST TIME
JUST IN THE FINAL DAYS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AFTER
MONTHS OF CLOSED DOOR
NEGOTIATIONS WHERE CITIES,
COUNTIES, ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS WERE
EXCLUDED ON THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
NEW BILL. AB 98 THRUST,
EXTENSIVE CIRCULATION ELEMENT
UPDATE REQUIREMENTS ON ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, 483 CITIES AND 58
COUNTIES WITH NO REGARD TO THE
ACTUAL APPROVAL AND DEVELOPMENT
OF LOGISTICS USE AND WAREHOUSES
IN COMMUNITIES AND THE ONLY
ENFORCEMENT FINES OF $50,000
EVERY SIX MONTHS ARE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMPLETE THIS
CIRCULATION ELEMENT UPDATE, WITH
NO OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL AROUND TRUCKING
STANDARDS OR WAREHOUSE GREENING,
COUNTIES HAVE ESTIMATED THAT
CIRCULATION ELEMENT UPDATE COSTS
WOULD BE BETWEEN 100,000 AND
500,000 INDIVIDUALLY.
APPROXIMATELY 6 MILLION TO 2829
MILLION FOR ALL 58 COUNTIES. TO
COMPLY WITH THIS REQUIREMENT,
CITIES ESTIMATE A BROADER COST
RANGE BETWEEN 100,000 TO THE LOW
MILLIONS, APPROXIMATELY 48
MILLION TO 720 MILLION FOR ALL
483 CITIES. TO COMPLY WITH THE
CIRCULATION ELEMENT. REQUIRED
REQUIREMENTS. DUE TO THE GREATER
COMPLEXITIES OF INCORPORATING
TRAFFIC PATTERNS AND FEWER
CHOICES, CHOICES TO DE-CONFLICT
FREIGHT MOVEMENT FROM
RESIDENTIAL TRAFFIC ON CITIES
ROAD NETWORKS, AB 98 DISREGARDS
THE ENORMOUS LOCAL COSTS THAT
WOULD LIKELY BE QUADRUPLED FROM
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR. THAT WILL REQUIRE A SAFETY
ELEMENT UPDATE A CONSERVATION
ELEMENT UPDATE, BICYCLE SAFETY
UPDATES ALONG WITH THE
CIRCULATION ELEMENT IN AB 98, WE
COULD HAVE ADDRESSED THESE
CONCERNS AND WAYS TO REDUCE
THESE COSTS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. HAD WE HAD A SEAT
AT THE TABLE, WE URGE A NO VOTE
ON AB 98. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, SKYLAR
WONACOTT, HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA, AS
WELL AS AND COALITION OF IN
OPPOSITION OF 18 BUSINESS
GROUPS. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST OWNERS AND
LEASERS OF WAREHOUSE SPACE
IMPACTING VITAL AGENCIES LIKE
CALTRANS. YET THERE HAS BEEN NO
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BILL. AND
LET ME BE CLEAR THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC IMPACTS.
EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS SHOW THAT
REDUCED MARKET SHARE IN SECTOR
LEADS DIRECTLY TO JOB LOSSES AND
BUSINESS, AND DECREASED IN STATE
LOCAL TAX REVENUE. BUSINESSES
INCREASINGLY CITING CALIFORNIA'S
STRINGENT REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
AS MAJOR FACTOR IN THEIR
DECISION TO LEAVE THE STATE.
MEANWHILE, THE STATE, LIKE
GOOGLE, GEORGIA, TEXAS AND SOUTH
CAROLINA ARE POURING BILLIONS
INTO THEIR TRADE SECTORS TO LURE
THESE COMPANIES AWAY. THE DATA
DOESN'T LIE. THE BILL PUTS US AT
A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE. THE
BILL MANDATES THE ADOPTION OF
NEW TECHNOLOGIES, SOME THAT ARE
STILL IN THE COSTLY FIRST
GENERATION PHASE AND OTHERS THAT
DON'T EVEN EXIST YET. THIS WILL
FURTHER DRIVE UP COSTS. IT WILL
ALSO CHANGE THE WAY CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND THEIR PLANNING
PROCESSES. ADDING EVEN MORE
FINANCIAL BURDENS AND DELAYS.
WHAT'S MORE, THIS BILL IMPOSES
FINES AND NONCOMPLIANCE ON
PERMITTING ENTITIES TRACKING ON
ADDITIONAL COSTS. IT EXTENDS
TIMELINES FOR DEVELOPERS PUSHING
PROJECTS OUT OF THE STATE OR
INTO NEIGHBORING STATES LIKE
ARIZONA AND NEVADA. THE
CUMULATIVE EFFECT, A CHILLING
EFFECT ON INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA, ULTIMATELY LEADING
TO MIDDLE CLASS JOB LOSSES AND
THE TRADE SECTOR, WHERE THE
AVERAGE WAGE IS OVER $87,000 A
YEAR. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
DEVASTATING. THE SECTOR HAS A
KEY IS A KEY DRIVER OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS HOMEOWNERSHIP IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE, AND IS A
VITAL SOURCE OF WELL-PAYING JOBS
FOR LATINOS. THOSE WITHOUT
COLLEGE EDUCATION AND
IMMIGRANTS. SINCE 2006,
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY LOST OVER
A HALF $1 BILLION IN TAX REVENUE
DUE TO THE SHRINKING MARKET
SHARE IN THIS SECTOR. AT A TIME
WHEN THE STATE AND LOCAL BUDGETS
ARE UNDER PRESSURE, THIS BILL,
AB 98, THREATENS TO FURTHER
ERODE CRITICAL TAX REVENUE NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE. LET'S NOT LET
THIS BILL UNDERMINE OUR ECONOMY,
OUR JOBS AND OUR FUTURE, AND WE
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS JASON
GONSALVES, REPRESENTING THE
CITIES OF ELK GROVE, FONTANA,
ROSEVILLE, CHINO, LAKEWOOD,
KERMAN AND INDUSTRY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. I GUESS THE GOOD
NEWS IS WE PROBABLY HAVE 40 OR
PLUS MORE IN OPPOSITION. IF
THERE WAS MORE TIME FOR THEM TO
KNOW WHAT'S COMING THEIR WAY.
BUT ON THE FISCAL ASPECT THE
CITY HEARD FROM, I SHOULD HAVE
SAID, OKAY, FAIR ENOUGH. I
APOLOGIZE ON TWO FOR AND TWO
AGAINST. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. DON Kò,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION, ALSO IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. DANIEL
CONWAY, CALIFORNIA GROCERS AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, MAX
PERRY, ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF RIALTO AND RIVERSIDE IN THE
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, DENNIS
ALBIANI, ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE MIDSIZE
BUSINESSES THAT WILL BE AFFECTED
BY THIS WHEN THEY TRY TO EXPAND
AND UPGRADE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. JENNIFER FEARING,
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR ROSS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF STOCKTON IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. SHARON
GONSALVES, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF BAKERSFIELD, BEAUMONT,
CORONA, EASTVALE, RANCHO
CUCAMONGA AND MERCED IN
OPPOSITION, ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
EXPRESS THE OPPOSITION OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MARK
NEUBERGER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION AND ALSO ALIGNING THE
ESTIMATE THAT CAL CITIES
PROVIDED THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF VISALIA AND THE MILK
PRODUCERS COUNCIL, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, JEFF NEAL,
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF CHULA
VISTA. AND ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA, ALSO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ASHA
SHARMA, ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE'S COLLECTIVE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE, CENTER
FOR COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE, AND CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS IN OPPOSITION,
REITERATING THERE IS NO ISSUE AT
THE TABLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RUBY ACEVEDO COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, AMY
JENKINS, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ONTARIO, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SPENCER STREET ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF CHINO HILLS,
COMPTON, DINUBA, HESPERIA AND
IRVINE. IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. HI. JACOB EVANS WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. HELLO, RAQUEL MASON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
REGISTERING OUR OPPOSITION. ALSO
WANTED TO REGISTER FOR THE
CENTER FOR COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH COALITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. KATIE
VALENZUELA WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AIR QUALITY COALITION,
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NETWORK. CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ASTHMA COLLABORATIVE AND VALLEY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS, AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BROUGH
MØT, CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE REGISTERING
OPPOSITION FOR PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, LA CENTER
FOR RACE, POVERTY AND
ENVIRONMENT, AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE. THANK YOU. GONZALEZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE AND THE CITY
OF PICO RIVERA. OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, PHOEBE. SENIOR
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY, ALSO ON
BEHALF OF FRESNO BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES IN CULTIVA
LA SALUD, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, NATALIE BROWN WITH THE
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. DYLAN ELLIOTT,
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF
FRESNO, TULARE, KERN, PLACER AND
SAN JOAQUIN, ALL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
ROSS BUCKLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MARK
FENSTERMAKER, FOR EARTHJUSTICE
AND OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LAUREN DE VALENCIA,
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. THIS WILL BE THE LAST. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MOYAMOYA. ON BEHALF
OF BOTH THE ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL AND THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF
OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ANDREW
MENDOZA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ANGELA ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT, THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU,
JEANNIE WALLER, ON BEHALF OF ACE
IN OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING
NO OPPOSITION AS I SAID BEFORE,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
WITH US. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY THE COMMITTEE? THANK
YOU. SENATOR. THANK YOU, I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS ON A
POLICY STANDPOINT, BUT I'D LIKE
TO MOVE IT OVER TO THE FISCAL
STANDPOINT, THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF CONCERNS FROM OPPOSITION. AND
I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS. YOU IN
PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS, ARE
WE IN AGREEMENT THAT THERE ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE SOME EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE AND KIND OF FIX SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT OPPOSITION IS
CONCERNED WITH IN THE FUTURE?
OKAY. FROM BOTH AUTHORS. YES.
ALL RIGHT. I MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY. THERE IS A MOTION. YEAH.
QUICK, QUICK COMMENT, FIRST OF
ALL, APPRECIATE EVERYBODY IN THE
ROOM. APPRECIATE ALL THE MOSTLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE OUTREACH
FROM EVERYBODY, YOU KNOW, IT'S
NOT VERY OFTEN THAT I GET LIKE A
HANDWRITTEN LETTER FROM ONE OF
MY MAYORS. ONE OF MY COUNCIL
MEMBERS JUST CAME THROUGH HERE
TO THAT MIC. SO, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU'RE IN SACRAMENTO, IT'S FRONT
ROW SEAT TO ALL THOSE LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS. THEY CAN COME
RIGHT OVER ON THEIR LUNCH HOUR
TO THIS HEARING. AND THEY'RE
REALLY STRUGGLING WITH THIS ONE.
I HAVE A LOT OF AS I TOLD YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO, I HAVE A
LOT OF LOCAL OPPOSITION. AND SO
I AM GOING TO VOTE. I IN HERE
TODAY. BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
REALLY CLEAR THAT I'M RESERVING
THE RIGHT ON THE FLOOR TO CAST A
DIFFERENT VOTE. I'M LOOKING AT
THIS BILL VERY CAREFULLY. I NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THE FINANCIAL
RAMIFICATIONS AT A LOCAL LEVEL.
AND I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW,
RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE. AT FIRST
GLANCE, I FEEL LIKE CITIES OR
HIGH DENSITY AREAS ARE
DISADVANTAGED BY THIS LAW
BECAUSE THEY HAVE LESS LAND TO
WORK WITH AND THEREFORE, ONE OF
YOU GOT UP AND SAID, HEY, THE
SETBACKS ALLOW FOR PEOPLE TO
LIVE, WORK, PLAY IN ONE SPACE,
SURE, BUT NOT WITHIN 900FT OF
WHERE THEY'RE WORKING. SO THAT
MAKES IT HARDER FOR US TO BUILD
HOUSING. WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH SMALL SPACES IN SACRAMENTO
AND ELK GROVE AND PLACES LIKE
THAT. SO I JUST NEED A LITTLE
MORE TIME TO LOOK AT IT. I KNOW
I HAVE A VERY LITTLE TIME, BUT I
HOPE WE AT LEAST HAVE A COUPLE
MORE HOURS TO REVIEW IT. I WILL
SAY IF THERE IS ONE THING GIVING
ME SOME COMFORT IN THIS, IT'S
THAT I KNOW THAT THIS PARTICULAR
AUTHOR, AND I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED
ON IT FOR A LONG TIME, BUT I
KNOW YOU'RE A SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT. THAT COMES FROM A
PLANNING DIVISION IN A CITY, AND
THAT GIVES ME A LITTLE BIT OF
COMFORT. THERE BUT I NEED MY
EYES NEED TO CONTINUE TO REVIEW
THIS FOR MY OWN REGIONS IMPACTS.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
COR. THANK YOU, MOST OF MY
ISSUES WERE STATED THE OTHER DAY
ON THE POLICY PART. THE FISCAL
PART OF THIS IS DOWN TO THIS.
THERE'S MAJOR STATE COSTS TO
IMPLEMENTING THIS, AND WE DON'T
HAVE A MAJOR STATE BUDGET TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THOSE COSTS. AND
THERE'S ALSO EVEN MORE MAJOR
LOCAL CITIES COSTS ON BOTH ENDS,
BOTH THE REVENUE SIDE FROM
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PERSPECTIVE, BUT ALSO FROM THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE AND THE
PLANNING. AND YOU KNOW THAT ALL
THE PLANNING, ALL THOSE STUDIES,
ALL THOSE THINGS COST MONEY. SO,
SO IN THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE
IN, ESPECIALLY IN THE UNCERTAIN
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE IN, AS
FAR AS OUR REVENUES ARE
CONCERNED, THEY SEEM TO BE
SHRINKING AND WE DON'T HAVE A
GOOD HANDLE ON THAT, IT IS HARD
FOR ME TO SUPPORT A BILL THAT IS
GOING TO PUT A STRAIN ON BOTH
THOSE SIDES, ALL THOSE SIDES OF
THE ECONOMIC PICTURE FOR US AT
THIS TIME. THE OTHER PART OF
THAT IS IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
INCLUDE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR TRYING
TO COMPLY WITH YOUR LEGISLATION,
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO INCLUDE
THEM AT THE TABLE TO GET THEIR
INPUT. I IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THAT. SO THIS I WILL NOT
BE SUPPORTING IT. I WISH YOU
WOULD TAKE IT BACK. INCLUDE SOME
OF THE OTHER GROUPS THAT NEED TO
BE INCLUDED IN THE EJ GROUPS,
AND ALSO THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES, AND COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON HOW THIS CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED WITHOUT BANKRUPTING
EVERYBODY. ANY OTHER COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS, MY COLLEAGUES? I'LL
STILL BE REVIEWING IT, BUT
CERTAINLY SUPPORTING IT HERE
TODAY IN APPROPRIATIONS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR LONG, HARD WORK
ON IT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND I'M GOING TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO AREA. AS SOMEONE WHO
SPENT 12 YEARS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, I KNOW THE CONCERNS
AND I'VE HEARD FROM MANY OF THE
CITIES IN MY DISTRICT, BUT I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE HERE. AND I'M ALSO GOING
TO YIELD TO YOUR EXPERTISE AS A
FORMER PLANNER, BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT GOES INTO THAT WORK. SO I
KNOW YOU'RE NOT DOING IT WILLY
NILLY, BUT DEFINITELY NEED TO
GET INTO THE WEEDS A LITTLE BIT
MORE BETWEEN NOW AND THE FLOOR.
VOTE THANK YOU. SO LET ME JUST
SAY THAT I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS AND I DO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES. WE HAD LONG
CONVERSATIONS OVER A PRIOR BILL
THAT YOU WERE WORKING ON, AND
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE, THE
OPPOSITION IS ON IS FROM TWO
SIDES OF THE ISSUE. THE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SEE LESS OF THESE FACILITIES
AND THE CITIES WHO WANT TO SEE
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO
CONTROL THEIR OWN FUTURE. AND
COMING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
I'M, I'M SENSITIVE TO THAT. AND
SO IT'S A CHALLENGE TO KIND OF
DRIVE THIS TRUCK RIGHT THROUGH
THE MIDDLE. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT, ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE, THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
HERE, I'LL ALLOW YOU TO CONCLUDE
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE UP OUR VOTE.
SO IF YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO ANY OF
THE THINGS THAT WERE SAID, THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING US HERE, IN
CLOSING, I JUST LIKE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED AND THE NOTION THAT
THIS BILL, AB 98, IS GOING TO
INTRODUCE NEW REQUIREMENTS ON
COUNTIES AND CITIES, GENERAL
PLANS, AS WELL AS ALL THE
MANDATED ELEMENTS OF THE GENERAL
PLAN, INCLUDING THE CIRCULATION
ELEMENT. THOSE ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE BY STATE LAW, BY PLANNING
LAW, CITIES, COUNTIES, THEY
ALREADY HAVE TO COMPLY WITH AN
UPDATED GENERAL PLAN. AND AS
WELL AS THOSE MANDATED SEVEN, I
BELIEVE MANDATED ELEMENTS. THE
CIRCULATION PLAN BEING ONE OF
THEM. SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THIS IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT,
IT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR MANY
DECADES, AND CITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH IT. THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
MANDATES ANYTHING NEW FROM
CITIES. AGAIN, IT'S ALREADY BEEN
IN PLACE. AND YET THERE WILL BE
SOME COSTS BECAUSE CITIES HAVE
TO UPDATE GENERAL PLANS AND
ELEMENTS. AND THOSE COSTS ARE
ALREADY DONE THROUGH THE
BUDGETING PROCESS IN THOSE
CITIES. AND COUNTIES. SO WHEN WE
HEARD THAT 483 CITIES AND 58
COUNTIES AND THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT GOES INTO UPDATING THESE
PLANS, IT IS TRUE. HOWEVER,
THERE IS NOTHING ON EVERY 98
THAT SAYS THAT THEY HAVE TO COME
UP WITH NEW SOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLY WITH STATE LAW. THAT'S
ONE THING, AND CAN I INTERRUPT
YOU REAL QUICKLY? DOES DOES THE
BILL AND WE'VE ALL READ IT. YES.
IN A FAIRLY COMMONSENSE TIME
PERIOD, DOES IT REQUIRE THAT THE
UPDATES BE DONE BEFORE THE
REGULAR CYCLE WOULD, WOULD,
WOULD COME FOR THAT PARTICULAR
CITY OR THE COUNTY OR HOW HOW IS
IT SET UP? WELL, WE ALIGN IT
WITH THE REQUIRED HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT GETS TO BE UPDATED
EVERY EIGHT YEARS. SO IN THAT
SENSE, CITIES THAT ALL CITIES
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH IT NOT
BECAUSE OF AB 98, BUT HOUSING
ELEMENTS HAVE TO BE UPDATED
EVERY EIGHT YEARS. THAT'S HOW WE
ALIGN THOSE CITIES THAT DON'T
HAVE A COMPLIANT CIRCULATION
ELEMENT, SO THAT THE WORK CAN BE
DONE, CAN BE DONE CONCURRENTLY,
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF SAN
BERNARDINO, THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND THOSE CITIES THAT ARE LISTED
IN THE BILL, SPECIFICALLY WHERE
THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN BUILDING
WAREHOUSES. THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S, I THINK
THAT DEALS WITH THE WHOLE ISSUE
OF IT'S GOING TO COST US MONEY.
NOW, IF THEY CAN DO IT DURING
THE REGULAR UPDATE, THEN THAT
THEY'LL HAVE TO DO IT ANYWAY.
YOU HAVE TO DO IT ANYWAY. OKAY.
VERY GOOD. YES, MADAM CHAIR.
YES, SENATOR. I BELIEVE THE
OTHER DATE IS JANUARY 1ST OF 26.
IT HAS TO BE DONE. THAT'S WHAT
HE JUST SAID. YES, YES. IT
DOESN'T. IT DOESN'T ALIGN WITH
THEIR HOUSING THING. SOMEBODY
JUST DID THEIR HOUSING IN 2024.
THEIR NEXT HOUSING ELEMENT IS
2032. THIS HAS TO BE UPDATED IN
2026. LET ME SEE THOSE CITIES IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. ALL RIGHT. SO
YOU MAY YOU MAY CONTINUE. I BEG
YOUR PARDON IF YOU HAVE OTHER
THINGS TO SAY, YOU MAY CONTINUE
IT IN YOUR CLOTHES. I JUST WANT
TO CLOSE BY ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE
AND SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. NO FURTHER
COMMENTS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
JONES. ASHBY AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE CIERTO. CIERTO.
NO. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE ONE. BILL
HAS 5 TO 1 VOTES. WE'RE GOING TO
PUT IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE. APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE. SO LET'S LET'S GO THROUGH
THE ROLL THROUGH THE ROLLS ONE
LAST TIME. WE'LL START WITH WELL
THIS WAS FILED ITEM NUMBER ONE.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON. IF I COULD ASK
FOR THE AUDIENCE TO PLEASE EXIT
QUIETLY SO WE CAN FINISH OUR
BUSINESS HERE TODAY. THANK YOU.
I KNOW THEY'RE REALLY LOW. OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. SINCE WE JUST
TOOK UP FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE,
WHICH IS AB 1205 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER KHN PRESENTED BY
SENATOR GLAZIER, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB AYE. 7 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
OUT. 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB 2348 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. THE
ABSENT MEMBERS, PLEASE. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I
WAHAB WAHHAB. AYE THAT BILL IS
OUT 7 TO 0. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR ACR 210 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNET. THE ABSENT MEMBERS,
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. I WILL HAVE A HAVE A 5
TO 2. 5 TO 2. THAT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. SO WE WILL WAIT. FOR
ONE FINAL MEMBER TO SHOW UP FOR
FILE. ITEM NUMBER ONE.
SO WE'LL CALL THE ROLL. THE
FINAL ROLL FOR ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB 98 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES JONES. 5 TO 1. THIS BILL
IS OUT 5 TO 1. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT, SENATOR JONES WILL NOT
BE RETURNING TO THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S HEARING.
WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA, THE MEETING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.